there's a ton of people who've been
talking all about capital gains taxes
taxing the billionaires eating the rich
and whatever other claim that the
politicians and other folks want to levy
to simply rile up support for taking
wealth from successful people and trying
to redistribute it to the rest of the
citizenship well elon musk the world's
most successful and richest man he ends
up coming in with a tweet over the
weekend he said much is made lately of
unrealized gains being a means of tax
avoidance so i propose selling 10 of my
tesla stock do you support this and he
literally ran a poll on twitter there
have been over 3.5
million votes on this poll
57.9
of people have voted yes and 42.1
percent of people have voted no he
followed up the poll tweet where he said
i will abide by the results of this poll
whichever way it goes
on top of that he said note i do not
take a cash salary or bonus from
anywhere i only have stock thus the only
way for me to pay taxes personally is to
sell stock and so when you look at this
is elon musk making a mockery of all of
this conversation kind of
of course it makes zero sense to ask the
leaders of these large corporations the
innovators the entrepreneurs the people
who are building solutions remember elon
musk has done two things that the
government couldn't do he has ushered in
a brand new era of electric vehicles he
made it cool to own an electric vehicle
on top of that too is he created
reusable rockets literally rockets that
drive the cost of going to space further
and further down
now we go and we say to these people
every year i need you to sell
stock in order to pay taxes on
unrealized gains that doesn't make a lot
of sense or if we say i need you to sell
stock because you're just too damn rich
that didn't make a lot of sense either
america was built on the principles of
free markets on entrepreneurship on
innovation and on capitalism instead of
condemning the success of people instead
of trying to be abrasive to those who
have been successful we should instead
be saying to elon musk elon how did you
do it elon please what can we do to
educate other people so they can follow
in your footsteps
celebrating those that have been
successful is the mark of a thriving
growing sustainable durable society once
a society starts to eat their own and
starts to turn on themselves and starts
to condemn success and starts to levy
and say that our political and social
problems are not due to the poor
decision making of politicians or to the
economic monetary and fiscal policy
decisions but instead it's the rich
people the rich people are the cause the
rich people are bad people
that's when societies start to fall
apart we should celebrate success this
is absolutely insane that this is even a
conversation but elon musk coming out
hot 3.5 million votes saying should i
sell 10 of my tesla stock or not that'd
be over 20 billion dollars of stock the
tax bill depending on his tax rate could
be anywhere between four to 10
billion dollars pretty incredible to
watch all this play out
right on twitter but elon musk he's not
one to do things in a traditional sense
so let's see if he sells tesla stock
down over three percent to start the day
pretty damn cool to see the richest man
in the world taking his financial
decisions to a twitter poll